welcome back to 8701
so in this lecture we open a new chapter
the week interaction
so we are one by one adding together the
components we need in order to describe
all elementary particles in the
interactions
so now we're adding the third form of
interaction after the
qed and qcd we enter
into the discussion of the weak
interaction so let's have a look at the
standard mode
so we discuss gluons and qcd
and we saw that gluons coupled to
themselves
and also to all quarks because they
carry a charge
under the on the qcd color charge
we have also discussed the photon and
seen that the photon
they do not couple to themselves but
they coupled to all charged elementary
particles
those are the meta particles the
fermions the photon also couples to the
w
golden because that's electrically
charged so now what we want to do in
this
next chapter i want to fully understand
the
w and the z bottom and we will see
that they couple to all meta particles
we will also discuss how they might
couple to themselves
or the zebra then couples to the w
well that's the story of this entire
chapter and we'll take it one by one
as an introduction we start with the
farming rules
so having the feynman rules in place and
the cookbooks the recipe in order to
calculate decays
and scattering processes this is all we
need in order to get
moving okay so we can for example look
at
this vertex here or this this
[Music]
component of a primary diagram and what
we need
to analyze this is the propagator for
the w and z both one
and the vertex vector
so this vertex vector now looks a little
bit more complicated
um than for qed and qcd because the w
both on and the z boson they carry mass
okay so we have the additional vectors q
squared minus m square
and this q square over m square
term as well okay
um one interesting fact about this
vertex factor is what happens now
if q squared is much much smaller than m
square right basically get rid of those
components here
and we find a vertex vector which looks
similar
to the one we have in qed or however
there's no one over q squared term
but just in one over m squared one which
is constant
so we will see that we can describe this
in the context of the fermi theory
which is a low energy approximation of
the full theory of weak interaction
it's kind of an interesting concept um
and it extends to the entire
understanding of the standard model it
might be that our standard model
you know that we have all the packages
together describes
a lower energy approximation of a more
complicated more
uh holistic theory um which we then can
discuss under the
concept of um a
ground unified theory uh maybe with a
symmetry group which is
embedding the symmetry groups we need
for qe
qcd and the vegan direction all right
but that's uh
a side remark uh so we
we look at the permit theory a little
bit more later
um the vertex factor itself describing
the vertex here
is given here for the w and w both on
and also for the z boson
and it looks a little bit more
complicated than the vertex vectors we
have seen
so far so
what you notice that there is a
parameter which
uh is associated to the strength of the
interaction
um but there's in the gamma matrix but
there's also this term here which has
two components
there's a one and there's the gamma five
matrix
all right we have talked about gamma
gamma5 matrix already
and we can later identify those as
uh individual currents are coupling to
vector a vector current in an extra
current so this looks
even more complicated now for the zebo
zone because
here we have not just numbers of one but
an additional factor this vector c
v is a vector coupling and it's specific
for each fermion so each firmware has
one of those constants
and there's a second part of package or
set of constants
for the axial current you have a second
parameter here
which is the strength of the coupling of
the z-border
so at this point you just take this for
grounded and we can do our calculation
the next slide i'm going to explain to
you
what the corresponding numbers are what
those values are for those parameters cv
and zero
um later we will see how it comes to
this more complicated structure and why
there is a vector
and why there is an actual axial axial
current
in the weakened direction but for now we
just take this for granted and we just
take
it as as a recipe
so now for the neutral so we just have
seen that this is the vertex vector
and here for all fermions we list what
these values are for cv
and ca what you can see is okay for the
for the neutrinos the factor is one half
both for cv and for ca and for the
charged leptons and
and and quarks there's an even more
complicated term here
which includes the new parameter
sine square theta w the value of this is
28 degrees
sine squared e theta w is 0.231
um as a little bit of a preview here
already
the fact that there is this new
parameter and an angle
involved leads to or can be explained
later
by the fact that the weak interaction is
actually
a result of a mixing between
an original weak interaction and qed
so there's a mixing going on in other
another
words the the z both on itself is a
mixture between
the thing which call couples to the weak
part
of the particles and the part which
couples to the
electrically charged part of the
particle then you see that that's why
there is very simple factor for the
neutrinos who are
electricity neutral and a more
complicated term here
for the electrically charged particles
and you see that
this is the electric charge here or two
times the electric charge
of the particles okay
um but for now those are all just
constants and recipes to be used
one additional vote on the history of
the neutral charge of the neutral
weak current is given here um
so in the 60s and 70s the standard model
was
slowly developed a little bit more
slowly than we do in this class yeah
and there was the hypothesis that there
has to be something like a neutral
current somewhere
but it has never been observed in nature
and so with
this bubble chamber specifically the one
gargamel at cern
one was able to actually see those see
virtually
really see uh those interactions
for the first time and the first
pictures that have been taken
in the 1970s 1973 and
this picture here illustrator i will
explain this in a second
illustrates the interaction of a
neutrino coming in
into the bubble chamber making an
interaction
with an electron and then scattering off
kicking off the electron
um so what you see here is this incoming
this is
an antenna arduino kicking off an
electron
see the electron here the neutrino goes
off undetected just disappears
um you see here the electron
and then there's also two photons one
photon here
just use a different color and one
photon here
causing an electron positron pair
in the second photon here doing the very
same thing
and you can see those particles here
here and there we go here as well so
this is a bubble chamber with a bubble
chamber picture
we'll talk about bubble chambers very
briefly later in the lecture as well
um but they're very extremely important
and useful tools in order to illustrate
illustrate to visualize and measure
particle interaction all right so much
to the introduction and we'll
continue now with the next lecture
on talking about this mixture with
electro weak
mixture i was talking about before